[Music]
brought to you by t-mobile
now Netflix has included another reason
why t-mobile is America's best unlimited
network
hello everybody welcome to their honest
trailer commentary and we're here we are
to talk about Star Trek context
situation look I need this idea this out
right away this is a special episode
because this was led by one man yep it
wasn't Joe Star was it was Mr Dan Moreau
blue plate special bye Dan that's been
months months on this piece is a passion
project Dan yeah
we will watch together and now you've
brought a lot of outtakes that the fans
didn't get to see how do you feel now
that it's finally out in the world it's
great it's great at people seem to be
liking it which is the most important
thing this goes back a long time
that I started this I pitched this to
you in April when I saw that today is
the 30th anniversary of the premiere
Star Trek The Next Generation that's a
Tuesday it's like it seems like if we're
gonna do it we should do it and I went
to Andy and April and said hey I have
this idea and you said well I don't want
to rewatch all of it but if you want to
and I don't think he thought I was gonna
do it yeah it's sort of like if you do
it your tears that's a lot you've earned
it five years worth of capital all on
this trailer I know it's not gonna be
our most watched what a weird way to
spend your capital on doing more work
for you I wish I could go have the time
to do that again cuz it's its way I
imagine it was fun to go back and see
back-to-back it was I started in May
there's a hundred and seventy eight
episodes Marv and I rewatched every
single one of them front to back and
these are I showed this to these guys
that was crazy these are my notes the
they're they're broken down by category
by subcategory I don't know how many
pages it is but a living document it's a
living document Star Trek The Next
Generation I was saying my favorite
category heading is one called horny
Riker
but it's it's basically all the thing I
knew that if if this trailer was gonna
happen I knew it would take months to
rewatch and just keeping random notes
would not work so I made categories as
we went and seven seasons finished it
about six weeks ago wrote a draft showed
it to you guys you guys gave us some
great input did a rewrite recorded with
John did a cut gave it to you guys and
that timing was not planned maybe not
the best timing as far as but then you
guys probably was actually probably good
that I wasn't here because you were able
to bring a perspective and help me see
the light you were too close man it's
still otherwise can I share this trailer
of the day what's up guys sure the story
of you at the end of the day yesterday I
was really stressed out dad cuz I love a
damn came in and we had changed the
Kardashian run yeah because we all have
this feeling and I didn't know that you
had been I clearly had talked to
everyone else and passionately it sort
of reached basically did ignored our
note and put it back to leave had it and
I just in the middle three things Bing
comes in and I'm like well the joke
didn't work we all know and then dannis
amigos like you could just tally as this
was like now he was just questioning
himself and then I was like you know
what take nor my note well you know I
mean it's a joke that I've been making
for years and it's a really tired kind
of hacky joke but do what you want to do
that was keeping up with the kardashians
Kardashian's joke was felt like but
there was a child Jenner joke yeah look
I was obviously but that joke was a
fellow cell but it wasn't even that
there was the combination of the orderer
which we now it stands it says dans ways
now but we had thought the Kardashian
get there when we get there this is not
after all you've done I don't want this
to be the the internal argument that we
had in between all of us of you said it
was our Kardashian joke and I said it
was a Kardashian joke
explain myself when I saw you defending
and saying no it's our Cardassian joy
guys like I'm never gonna win the way
let him go finish it cuz I was like all
right he's thought this through I gotta
have his back on this one but here we
have it it's the damn directive yeah but
yeah this was the big when people ask
why we don't do honest trailers of TV
shows it's because it literally took us
three months just to watch the show and
then I mean it's it's such an
undertaking and it's not something that
we want to do the cliff say sorry it's
not happening as often as you'd like it
to do lost joys things like we'd love to
you it just yeah when I remember and Joe
helped me tremendously but I I was going
to do the rewatch of the flash and
finally go through the flash that's what
we ultimately like let's stand we were
doing the flush the timing on that one
work to because I had like just watched
the whole season because we were doing
the show and so the rewatch had already
happens yes I didn't do that these
episodes had I noticed these the prisons
and all the stuff that we lost some of
the jokes that made it in there and they
Joe tighten it up and Spencer obviously
times there's some shorter shows that we
might address yeah the unfortunate
takeaway for a lot of fans I think here
is we're proud yeah unless we do it from
the perspective of people who've never
watched doctor that they tossed around
I'm like that won't go over well they
adored Spencer saying he sort of enjoyed
an episode now I'm getting a lot of
recommendations well this is a long one
anything else we should probably just
get it now takes - yeah lot about takes
video I want dance commentary engage
video engages now great
it's number one I do that have we all
watched next change because I love next
generation I sent a free watch Star Trek
discovery forces you to boldly subscribe
where no one has subscribed before
celebrate the 30th anniversary of the
Star Trek spin-off that gave rise to the
ultimate nerd question I mean again this
was and you like that change or dislike
that I didn't find it I thought the
thing was funny or like as a Star Trek
fan like I immediately did what Star
Trek next generation does was like it's
a show that asks existential questions
like what is the nature of man and then
it ended with who's better Kirk or
Picard I do understand that the kirkuk
Picard is the joke and I was just
talking a compliment a little bit of
build up and come hang out outside the
fireworks pack yeah exactly so but I
they nailed that graphic I love yeah
that's fun but does CBS all access last
was a good question I I think yes they
have a lot of money
I think they'll sustain that just one
Big Bang Theory reruns young Sheldon was
the highest-rated big thing is the NFL
though you can watch the NFL in there
and that's huge like people that say do
you think this will bring some people in
for sure I mean yeah I Big Brother
brought me in a minute and I can't watch
the live feed guy you and Batman both
watch a lot of that is a smart guy yeah
but yeah I'm interested to see if we see
the [ __ ] got like 10 9 or 10 million
viewers on TV which is fasting to watch
the how that's all gonna go down but
it's such a big property is kind of
frustrating they have like 10 NCIS isn't
CSIS but they won't put a Star Trek on
his little disheartening but I think
they felt like that's the driver like
okay here's the franchise we can use to
drive people toward this thing and it's
got a passion of a following that maybe
will do it but the weird thing is is
like sure Star Trek is interesting like
that could get me to sign up but then
it's like stick around for for my
brother yeah exactly
or Big Bang Theory genre thing that was
maybe guys you can watch all of Cheers
that's cool I have to start checking I'm
gonna stick around for that from a genre
perspective CBS auxes is probably the
last place some of my Star Trek
as a Star Trek fan 2 Broke Girls and I
don't know just it's like a bunch of
weird sitcoms and I feel like to an F
man I've never actually watched anyone
be honest but to Sheldon's yeah Sheldon
I don't know not my cup of tea Big Bang
Theory there's no crossover there Big
Bang Theory was funny in the beginning
although Star Trek fans probably say Big
Bang Theory is for what it is it's the
show for norming started it started
better but yeah I know I can see that I
see the hate on the show your parents
think you should go right for we're just
like the guys in Big Bang Theory you
should write for that Big Bang Theory
yeah all right
Star Trek The Next Generation your dad
loved the original Star Trek's mix of
campy aliens cheesy telling you and razz
developer acting now get ready for the
original series geeky younger brother
featuring new aliens more complex
stories and acting that's way better
than Star Trek deserves in this kinder
gentler sequel where crewmembers discuss
their feelings celebrate each other's
cultures and fight with their words not
their fists I hereby formally request
the big thing is I get it no like the
next generation I get people that say
that it's a bit of it's news like I
understand it but I appreciate it for
what it is but I did want to acknowledge
that yes the original series is action
and camp and you know it does more than
that people don't not remember that but
yes next generation is very talky and
there's a lot of meetings first season
or two there couldn't be any inter crew
conflicts Gene Roddenberry had a rule
before he passed that there could be no
internal conflicts on the show like all
of the conflicts had to come from
meeting
extre that's why the first few seasons
the show is like it's all that kind of
the alien of the week or the planet of
the weakest you dried berries like well
in the future everyone gets a
so of course no one would fight and he
also had a rule that there could be no
continuing storylines which is a writer
I'm sure was very rough
yeah difficult so as he got ill and then
unfortunately passed away while next
generation was on the air
the writers kind of had a little more
license to take the show in a different
direction which you know I don't think
this is the sort of thing he's wrong I
think he's just he had a very
objectified view of the future and I
think he may have injected a little bit
too much of that into the early years
that's why Star Trek next generation I
will also admit doesn't really get
consistently good until the third season
the first two or the first one is really
spotty second one has some good moments
but also has a clip show and the third
one is when it starts to and that's
constantly justify the clip show well
here's what happened
commander Riker beamed down to a planet
and got stung in the leg by this plant
that was killing him and they found that
the only way to save his life is to
stimulate chemicals in his brain that
are brought on by unpleasant memories so
they were stimulating bad memories of a
time on the other Clips yeah think bad
things that happened to Riker here's
what happened there's a writer's strike
and then ran out of time brilliant yeah
called changer a and most people think
it's the one of the worst episodes if
not the worst of the show and I would
not disagree worse than guy crushers
weird dead grandma they can crush you
the Beverly Crusher bones of space well
we'll get to that to keep playing bring
warp in to the 24th century with an
all-new USS Enterprise and awkward
hybrid of cutting-edge Space Battleship
and a Marriott Convention Center my
detective story and me and all new crew
counselor Troi and empath who can always
tell when someone's lying except when
she can't what do you think it's hard to
tell
I sense nothing what is it at this club
I don't know
something selves in have corner with her
just because she could solve a lot of
the problem no she's an instant
lie-detector like immediately like
challenge her to not always be on the
figure like yeah blocking my powers
somehow they're still my fun backstory
for her is that she's lying
yeah she like flunked some test and was
like oh but I'm an empath too
she was also the one that was the most
poorly treated by the show I think her
character was literally there to be fall
in love with records I had to be
defaulted to follow up with Riker and to
have like the only person on the ship
that was in a unitard like a leotard for
like five years
like what do you why come on come on
it's like they wear some pants
yeah which they did eventually but yeah
Troy Troy got short shrift
I think I'll surely crusher though
digression short trip to she got some
good storylines but Troy was the one
that they were just like oh she's the
eye candy like the future remember her
yeah we're trying this 20 century still
is not advanced beyond there's still
boners in the future day and apparently
so alright
Geordi LaForge a blind engineer who's
here to say tech words a cosmic string
emanate the characteristics set a
subspace frequencies never runs out of
Klingon prescribe that thing Klingons do
not procrastinate Klingons do not allow
the results to be proved Lieutenant
Commander data and Android who drops
being an Android into conversations like
your friend who just became a bigot
[Laughter]
originally an angel addressed me in
joining the conversation like a
vegetarian at a barbecue and that's a
nice ignore reference and there are
literally dozens of clips of data
throughout the show saying I am an
Android
this is a this is a literally tell you
exactly how many I'm sure I did yeah I
see this is I don't know if you can see
but there's literally this whole column
here is yeah there you go
Excel man what can you does everything
continue engage I became a vegan why do
you have yellow eyes I am an Android
you're not human I'm an Android you some
like you don't want to be an Android I
am an Android the horniest first officer
in the fleet who's never met a woman
hologram co-worker amnesia stricken crew
member or genderless androgynous alien
he didn't want a boat commander tell me
about your sexual organs who's just kind
of there most of the time her son Wesley
whose genius is matched only by his
skill at irritating people I know it's
make finish me as an acting ensign I
think this is my style shut up kid may I
point out but shut up Wesley everybody
needs somebody get off and loop the
calming and defensive Wesley Crusher
that kid saved the ship more time Geordi
or data or Riker like I'm playing a
video game and he's heaven in Sarabi
luffler job like Wesley I get it like
he's an annoying teenager that but
that's annoying teenage like that's his
character so I feel like he's got and
I'm sure this honest trailer will do
nothing to help again the original draft
went into how smart Wesley was and that
but he also the only thing and he
remembers but it's brevity and humor but
I will defend Wesley Crusher and say
like yes he's annoying sometimes
no no there should be children well
we'll see that in the deleted thing
there should be children on the ship
right but there definitely shouldn't be
children on the bridge I will agree with
that what about a genius coming for that
crossover and yes Captain jean-luc
Picard make it so the most British
Frenchman in the galaxy tío gray hot
excellent
good-day contain one of the world-class
actor Patrick Stewart remain fully
committed to his even when the riders
clearly fell asleep on their keyboards
[Music]
elders who remembered the Romulans
Klingons and Vulcans from the original
series now get ready for all news from
an episode called I believe it's called
from where silence has lease and he
traps the enterprise and this weird void
and there's like probing them and can't
figure out what they are and he's gonna
destroy them they didn't have a lot of
time to do things often and Nick Elam is
one of the more regrettable and really
just creepy
yep yeah this is orange or something
looks like the baby from ghostbusters 2
yeah kinda all new species with all new
ways to glue prosthetics to people's
faces like the best Star Trek villains
ever the board the Ferengi literal butt
heads in serious need of a dental plan
Poochyena and omnipotent tricksters with
a serious man crush on Captain Picard
morning Tony the Kardashians appearing
omnipresent leather skin tyrants bent on
galactic domination I'm sorry what's
that oh sorry
and the Cardassian omnipresence
who are they what a pervert all right so
this is the great Kardashian Kardashian
debate of 2017 what I get if you are
right it is that Kardashian yeah like
you guys kept telling me like no you're
saying the Kardashians up fronting
you're spoiling the punchline and I was
saying like no part of Kardashians are
the punchline the Kardashians are the
set up and that that was where our great
yeah thanks China right was the and the
Kardashians leather skin tyrants not to
be confused with the Kardashians and the
fertilizer skin tyrants yeah but then it
was like wow if Lawrence is still being
felt today I'm like well the Kardashians
didn't really influence the Kardashians
like that seems a bit of a stretch
maybe tacky I don't know real timeline
the Kardashians would have been first
right yes definitely bastions were III
was very confident in that joke
obviously
I [ __ ] all three of you and said in
any fight we fight or otherwise and you
were so passionate about they're like go
for it fine oh I wish I had known the
know before he came in I'll let history
to say tyrants bent on galactic
domination was our what's that oh sorry
again and in your Dacia omnipresent
leather skin tyrants been done galactic
domination not sure which one I prefer
like the Kardashians journey to a sci-fi
utopia where poverty racism and war are
things of the past and forget the
original Star Trek's miniskirt boys club
she does a good job alright it's just a
night that's the point just having a
woman on the bridge yes because this
enterprise the future is whoa Klingons
appreciate strong women we no longer
enslave animals for food purposes I have
decided to allow my child to choose its
own sex and appearance well both of the
time
okay well at least things are better
right I mean the ladies aren't all
stereotypical anymore I've never met a
chocolate I didn't like damn it Roy
against Roy so we live one of the
greatest pieces of science fiction ever
created full of unforgettable moments
and a view that they wish you would
forget like the time the gang met Mark
Twain shame on you mr. Clemens shame the
one where Captain Picard turns into a
kid
I need to see him now and the episode
where dr. crusher inherits a lab that
contains a Space Ghost animates her
grandmother's corpse and attacks her
friends damn right was that is never so
called Sabrosa
it is about a planet that is replicated
the the the culture of Scotland on their
planet and it turns out that the crusher
women I forget her maiden name but it's
on that side not her husband's side Oh
crusher can they as time has gone on
they each inherit this candle that's a
family heirloom and they also have had a
lover and later in their life and it
turns out that this being feeds himself
off their life force by because I
basically United with them as a lover
they've grown in a typical man it was a
who stored in the candle that's his
power that's where his power comes from
so he has to break the up with that weak
in the writers room there he finally got
a story though that was season seven
yeah season seven also has an episode
called masks where data is home to like
five different spirits including one
called moussaka and slowly turns the
enterprise into an ancient temple
there's one called Genesis where
everyone D evolves into animals we have
more types of terrible okay I think I
think they knew that the end was coming
running out
running out of ideas and they were just
like here's something weird at seven
also has some great episodes by the way
but season seven is definitely the one
that has the most like kind of like what
I live watch Subrosa with you I need to
see that [ __ ] together it's it's quite
something bring the ghost that was our
fate that's great and I hope he did a
teaser we spelled trailers wrong yeah I
asked why that was still up and I was
told that the engagement was too high on
it engaged
you got to engage there's a Star Trek
it's like maybe we shouldn't have the
name of our show spelled wrong but I was
there's something with social media that
I don't understand look I must do on the
internet now it's hip to just put the
are you drop the e tumblr Grindr
mister yeah yeah we're just we inhibit
we're hip web 2.0 very hip yeah
Robert does stellar work by the way he's
allowed to have a that's tight he's a
lot of what he's a lot of type you're
allowed one Robert yeah let's keep
saying the starring store any of these
at different regional series cameos data
interrupted and what Klingons do to
their children they I'm not talking
about parenting he betrayed the
colonists and would have betrayed the
enterprise as well and I'm not the
unhatched eggs of a large-scale display
that data by the way guesses Jordan all
data and we are not my game Alexa the
same way
[Music]
doppelgangers the card mean faces two
famous Picard that one lightning effect
there was a guy in the comments that was
like that's the appropriate way to punch
a king okay definitely honest anyway I'm
not much of an actor the card maneuver
that's the punches kept it in yeah
the rhykker maneuver dr. Pulaski's being
shown to her quarters cause somewhere in
the comments made the observation or
some new information that he had a bad
back he had a back injury then was
uncomfortable for him to like do that
kind of squatting motion so that's why
he will be another Tuesday way it seems
like but it also makes sense I have
pages of notes that didn't make this
trailer at all of Riker leaning which is
if you watch the show Riker always is
also takes pressure off your back or
he's like this or he does the captain
what I call the Captain Morgan pose next
to David this or Haley always leans on
this or a little top he was also very
tall so it would make sense the back
thing made sense and also just like if
you're next to these crowns we kind of
gurney getting that shot quick out of
sneak into the shot it's it's what they
used to make Tom Cruise look the same
height as Anthony Edwards and Top Gun
it's just maybe I don't know but yeah so
that would make sense the back injury it
also fits his character he's like
swaggering it just like he had he has a
move when he walks I call it the
gunslinger ooh which is like he kind of
[ __ ] his shoulders like this arm just
swings let's do a heel turn and like he
had a very interesting physicality and
these chairs go low enough can we all
try a wrecker maneuver right now oh I
don't know yeah this is nothing people
might confuse this with the with the AC
Slater maneuver which is backwards
really different it's a straight in
there my chair does not have a lever on
it together
try mine no that's okay used to a lean
yeah it's pretty hard now do we raise
them a little and try it again like
limbo right go right go right there
right there right there right yeah
that's been out there in the ether for a
while the right person if you see as
this but that's something that kind of
like I remember you can't ignore it
well there were like the Shia LaBeouf no
no no no no yeah ever discovered that
first you are you are kudos endorsed a
weird person you may want to start
something like this if you don't look
like a person who came here to relax
something's wrong tell sir Troy's ill
okay more done yeah it does look he has
a back problem yeah this is much longer
run and there are a lot of concerts Lee
so many concerts
[Music]
and Worf getting his ass my defense was
like oh when Worf gets his ass kicked it
shows you that though that this is
serious they defeated a great yeah but
they do it so much but seriously go back
and watch the episode with dr. crusher
bones the space goes it's just it's it's
amazing literally right after that the
card walks in the door and it's a shot
that shows up like he walks in her from
his pew of you and she's like literally
like we wrote their you know they're
talking about season seven and how weird
that episode wasn't they're like we've
literally wrote an episode where doctor
where Captain Picard catches dr. crusher
masturbating and it made it onto network
TV so it can't be that bad but you know
measures emerging with her sure like
what the game episode you're talking
about the it's it it stimulates the
pleasure center of the brain so every
time they pass a level all the cast
members have to go and they all just
become zombies yeah well you're right TV
that long you get bored Disney animators
did all those we have sup yeah there's a
lot of stuff I think as much as we can
yeah more no this is the original
jurisdiction oh man being civilized is
boring
[Music]
yeah suck it words still not as
embarrassing as playing poo I didn't do
and improve USS Enterprise this is the
run you guys haven't seen yet I throw a
pre-emptive ly deleted this because I
felt out of every there are certain
things you had to have and I knew it was
too long and it's like I need to make
one big cut so before I even gave this
to you guys to do notes on I mean I
lifted this entire run so soon if I made
the right decision I don't know play
Brian's a state of the art ship packed
with advanced 24th century technology
that never works
helm and navigation controls are not
functioning the holodeck safeties have
been disengaged his weapon could be
lethal Enterprise cringe as Starfleet
packs this constantly malfunctioning
deathtrap to the gills with kids and
families and then sends them hurtling
into the never ending screensaver of
space what could possibly go wrong
we are a hostage situation on Dec 17 for
section reports 6 more children and dogs
great yeah the kid runs pretty brave it
is cruel to put children in danger by
bringing them aboard a starship in the
first place
see even Butthead knows it's a bad idea
I liked it too but I felt like you have
to have the crew thing in there you have
to have starring in there and I was like
everything that was left it felt like
something's got to go yeah brother and
that's sort of a Star Trek trope is that
this ship always has to explode always
something yeah every movie it blows up
I'm just kind of like can we not blow it
up in a movie and see what happens yeah
yeah that must be very expensive there's
no money right there's no money space
however there is there isn't there isn't
like the Starfleet has everything so I
don't know why always have a new
starship for everybody when so explode
Starfleet and nonprofit apparently the
world isn't on Starfleet no one has
money my understanding was is just like
post-scarcity and like because you can
make any the cost of producing something
is zero shouldn't just be like t v--
shows up there like what's the point of
buying anything if you could just make
it but they go to places that have money
right so I don't know how that they
negotiate that like is it just so
meaningless to them that they just carry
it around the trip and they trade for a
3d printer and there you go there you go
touch up unforgettable moments incisive
social commentary the episode rep Ricard
lives an entire life in 15 minutes and
gets a flute and tons of moments so
ridiculous you won't be able to guess
which one of these we made up like the
drugs are bad episode how can a chemical
substance providers
it doesn't but it makes you think it
does Nana's dead uh Dan are you sure
this is as good as you remember it is
star wars are unnecessary let's talk it
out title Star Trek the good one I mean
these space 9 had its moments in this
Voyager did too and the original series
is good for a nostalgia but come on
opening the flood come on signal the
following in all languages of male
frequencies we surrender oh so Captain
Picard is French after all that's the
sentence groundskeeper willie joke
apology city spoke to a delightful
frenchman it's now for you
Bravo Dan Moreau all right no listen
Star Trek next generation was very
meaningful not to not to get too serious
about a dumb trailer but start to
register she was very meaningful to me
because it was on when I was a kid when
I was 10 11 12 years old and it was not
easy to be into that kind of stuff and
you know I was about I was not a popular
kid and Star Trek was my escape and
particularly this show because it was on
I watched it I taped every single
episode and I read stuff about every
single episode and so if it seems like
this is a love letter to start to a
connection relations because it is
because this show has meant a lot to me
and I wanted to take this opportunity to
express even just a little bit my love
for this show and I know that everybody
has something like this so thank you for
indulging me I know like I said I know
this is not gonna be our wars trailer
ever but it's fun it was funded to
experience the rewatch like I said it'll
do better than how much as a phaser
worth yeah Star Trek episode that's true
do we have the the fight from not this
year's central but last year when he did
Trek fights set up
it's on my sergeants and we're doing
Star Trek fights tonight on TV fights
new is Dan I'll be fighting again I'll
do there it's a lot smort record store
to celebrate today's 30th anniversary of
next generation yeah good work man that
was a lot of work I could we all saw it
and well worth the time very fun and
nice little time capsule piece to
celebrate cuz you know Star Trek is not
gonna say anything they've hardly done
anything to celebrate this show which is
very depressing
I suppose I happen to run into somebody
who worked on the show who of course
Scott Manson ooh and it reduced me to
and I was very starstruck and I told
them like hey I'm working on an honest
trailer for the 30th anniversary of next
generation and they said well I'm glad
somebody's doing something because there
really hasn't there's been no fanfare
for this and it's like this was a
landmark sci-fi show and and the
original series had huge celebrations at
30 years and 40 years and 50 years and I
do feel like nobody's really paying
attention oh what to do with Star Trek a
lot of times which is disappointing so
not even on the product and just on the
interaction and now it's like we have
this property great let's put him on me
oh and we'll hide it behind a paywall
because the fans will pay for it right
it's just a whole I'm just going into
with into darkness I just felt like that
movie more than anything that Star Trek
has done in the last however many years
and I get that you things evolved but I
thought that into darkness really got it
was a real sign of just not showing
respect or even an understanding of what
hands bobble it's not a very franchise I
mean the fact that they're bringing a
series back should be on the level of
the force awakens like oh my god one of
the two groundbreaking original sci-fi
franchises are back Star Wars in
theaters Star Trek on TV yeah and
they're just making nothing out of it
yeah anyway I don't want to go in the
whole Paramount thing but I Star Trek's
a great franchise and this meant a lot
to me so I was glad that I could help
celebrate this landmark you know so far
I'm excited for them to watch and I hope
you had fun watching anything else dad
fellas you guys are gonna be so excited
about my honest trailer for every
iteration of transformers since it
premiered
of the cartoon you mean yes
right yes Spencer if you could do one
what would it be
[Laughter]
sci-fi stuff just a show that you have
to go back to show that you like you
know what I want to go back and watch
that show I did just re-watch every
episode of Seinfeld so I could probably
do that that's very fun yeah I did mine
did the flash recently yeah I don't know
I feel like lost has to happen at
something so that's the one on the list
it feels like it's probably worthy and
wonder if people still do they can get
the craters on the record to be like
yeah we screwed it's also tough in this
day and age with the internet where you
literally it's like you imagine doing
Empire Strikes Back in this day and age
you couldn't get away with it everyone
would be speculating you know end which
and becomes as someone on the set this
happens like oh it must be purgatory and
then it sort of was so it's like how do
you write yourself out of a thing where
every fan can write your ending quickly
and post it and have a million people
viewing a going yeah good luck beating
that one it's it's tough yeah yeah I
don't know anyway but this did you like
the ending of next generations the final
episode I love all good bad yeah yeah I
think it's great I think Scotty comes
back I remember we watching that was
really fun nostalgia thing where they
build they take the whole deck back and
he goes on the old bridge and realizes
sort of he's gotta move on yeah it was a
fire they've done some fun nostalgic
ones that feel like they could have been
really cheap stunts but they usually
figured out yes they did there I mean
there there are some stinkers but every
TV show 78 episodes you're gonna have a
handful that are really bad yeah but I
think on the average particularly from
season 3 on next generation was telling
some great stories and yeah you know
what I think you should share is because
I was looking at doing a rewatch and you
put together sort of an outline for me
of like if you don't have a whole lot of
time like here's like the core like good
stuff oh yeah sure I can do that
yeah just here's the guide here's the
you know my my everyone has a different
one but yeah I could definitely do that
I'm sure fans would like a to tell them
hey ya head up Dan on Twitter and thank
you all for watching we will see you
next week with another honest trailer
that should also be very funny
long and prosper brought to you by
t-mobile now family plans include
Netflix at no extra charge another
reason why t-mobile is America's best
unlimited network
[Music]
you